mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait qu'est ce
qu'elle peut bien faire françois qui
at-il encore quasi mais l heure est il
beaucoup de casimir d'une a déjà demandé
il ya trois minutes mais qu'elles ne
soient un petit peu
elle ne va pas tarder à arriver au mais
qu'est ce qu'elle peut bien faire c'est
pas possible j'ai pas possible pour toi
oui tu ne crois pas que je devrais aller
à sa rencontre
passé peut-être perdu n'écoute que et
mirel et avec julie elle ne peut pas
s'être perdu ne t'inquiète pas je te
répète qu'elle ne va pas tarder alors
les filles alors elles sont toujours en
retard du dont casimir 7 arrive jamais à
toi aussi d'être en retard peut-être moi
mais jamais au temps d'agir tu vas voir
dès qu'elle sera là je lui dirai ce que
j'en pense à rebonds et tu verras je
suis sûr qu'elle ne sera plus jamais en
retard ensuite à 0
voilà tu vas voir excuse moi je suis
très en retard auraient mis mon annonce
c'est ce n'est pas grave il ne fallait
pas dépêché dans les deux anti que tout
est joli dans cette île qui nos braves
ou casimir j'ai vu sarah quelleenergie
au hautbois occupe alors ce kit au
regard d'un bonbon celle-là ça merci
avec ce que vous seriez lunettes ou pour
y aller je suis prêt alors quand désires
tu vois tout je veux tout connaître de
l'île aux enfants
alors attention la grande visite de
l'île va commencer
d'abord c'est tout ce que c'est qu'une
île oui c'est cetus et de la terre
entourée d'eau de tous les côtés ça
alors mais comment sais-tu ça j'ai pas
deviné je l'appris à l'école tu devais
être dans une une très bonne école une
très bonne école bien alors nous
commençons la visite
d'abord nous sommes ici dans le jardin
ici se trouve le banc de lille le banc
du jardin
là c'est le kiosque de julie le kiosque
et puis ça va ressasser françois bon
journal est jean françois et tu as vu un
il parla paraît bien nous allons
traverser le petit bois et rejoindre le
sang en libye
tu vas voir c'est très beau à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure soit
[Musique]
olalala françois françois je suis
content de vous trouver je suis dans
l'embarras que vous arrive t-il facteurs
regardez cette enveloppe que lisez-vous
gelé d'où serait lé l'île aux enfants
ça vous dit quelque chose rien du tout
je m'en doutais depuis ce matin j'ai
posé la question à presque tous les
habitants de l'île enfin il faut
comprendre qu'une enveloppe mal fait
c'est un problème terrible pour nous
autres facteurs mais j'm'en de deux
facteurs tonné françois regarder voilà
j'ai écris aujourd'hui une lettre à ma
cousine eux la lutte et en parler bon
alors suivez moi bien je vais aussi
secteur voilà alors d'abord il faut
écrire monsieur madame ou mademoiselle
enfin ça ça c'est surtout de la
politesse mais en fait c'est très
important
ensuite vous marquez le prénom et le nom
de la personne à qui vous destinez votre
lettre
bon alors moi j'ai écrit mademoiselle
eulalie eulalie c'est son prénom donc et
campagne c'est son nom son nom de
famille et c'est le même que le mien
c'est tout à fait normal puisque nous
sommes cousins germains
du côté de mon père évidemment bien
ensuite vous marquez le numéro de la rue
enfin de la risle de l'avenue du
boulevard de la route que c'est chauffer
et ensuite le nom de l'arbre alors ici
j'ai écrit 23 rue du chemin de fer voilà
ensuite quand il s'agit d'une lettre
pour la france vous vous inscrivez le
code postal à ça ça ça alors là le code
postal c'est très important et ensuite à
côté
le nom de la ville c'est bien compris
bien
et enfin vous marquez le nom du
département et puis éventuellement le
nord du pays ça c'est surtout important
quand on écrit à l'étranger de cette
façon les facteurs pourront distribuer
plus facilement la lettre à son
destinataire
voyez vous mais alors quand vous voyez
des lettres on fait comme si elle si ça
c'est petit à vous dégoûter du métier je
vous comprends cette terre c'est
toujours très décevante
je ne pas boire à faire son travail
correctement pour sûr françois rohaut
mais que vous savez dire les choses je
suis pas de justesse à 15h au bonjour
casimir les jours mademoiselle collecte
je n'essaie pas bien c'est ma 3e julie
qui m'a parlé de bouille alors nous en
termes si flatteur que joe 17 vaut
connaître la gentil moi aussi j'avais
beaucoup entendu parler de la campagne
et oui oui c'est ça je représente à mon
tour louise tout sera elle des toilettes
dont on maquille canon avez vous dit
mais le dire le let est un surnom qu'on
m'avait donné lorsque j'étais tout petit
et mes amis appellent encore 1,6 mais
mon véritable nom et louise tout sereine
mais alors la lettre avec laquelle j'ai
parcouru toute l'île aux enfants ce
matin vous est destiné j'ai bien
rouillier facteurs quand on est
persévérant tout finit par s'arranger
avant pour sûr mais j'espère bien que ce
qui est contenu dans cette lettre est
important un parce que parce que je ne
serais pas content d'avoir fait un
trajet pour ja c'est mon petit frère qui
m'écrit un char molette puisque tu es
dans l'île aux enfants dit à casimir que
je l'aimé beaucoup c'est tout c'est tout
bas bon je trouve qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de nouvelles plus important au
tard françois françois retenez moi je
vous en prie aucun émoi la chantilly un
malheur mois